Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie.
This is going to be my walking dead mid season
finale video so much craziness.
So much stuff to set up for the back half
of the season so try to cover everything.
Just careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it yet.
There is a new round of The Walking Dead giveaway
going on now.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video be sure
to click that bell to enable alerts so you
don't miss anything during the break.
Let's do it the episode either Daryl who went
full Negan depending on which way you go
on it or Spencer who just totally went for
that brass ring for little bit short did not
quite stick the landing but it's okay I'm
sure Rosita found somebody else to have dinner
with that night, but that was kind of funny
like she holds him in such contempt that she
still relented and was like yeah okay I'll
have dinner with you whatever, but the whole
thing about this episode is that they're finally
coming to the conclusion that they need to
come together at the evening tease that in
the promo we need to work together to do something
about Negan so that is all marched toward
that's like the next volume in the comics
so that's what they're going to work through
to the back half of the season and then we'll
start teasing all out war and I know everybody's
asking who do those boots belong to there's
a new person that they cast all talk about
that is.
I work through top 10 WTF, but here we go
number 10 Maggie versus Gregory. Maggie for
president of hilltop.
You can see exactly what they're setting up
here.
The thing about Maggie is that Bino because
of what this episode was implying how the
gonna start fighting back.
They want to be hopeful.
Maggie is affectively invincible or I should
say untouchable is a better word inside the
writers room, so if you're making a short
list of characters that will probably never
die, at least anytime soon.
Maggie is close if not at the top of that
list, along with like Rick Michonne.
Daryl baby Judith, so give the pregnant lady
the apple they really want to make Gregory
seem like a super asshole, but he's a comic book
character he is a very specific comic book
arcs so you could totally read ahead and find
out where that goes.
Because it's going to be right out of the
comics so if you actually do want to read
ahead in the comics during the break.
March to war starts out with walking dead.
Volume 109 goes through 114 and then right
after that is all out war part one number
nine, comic book Neegan shaves himself just
like Rick in Rick's house very different scene
from when Rick shaved his beard back at the
beginning of season six.
Remember how big his beard had grown.
He was more beard than man.
At that point, but now the beard is totally
coming back.
So was so hilarious that Negan is losing
the beer beard equals power in The Walking
Dead so Rick's beard is like slowly growing
back out, just as Negan shaves his, so
it's a bit of a hat tip to the shift in power
on the show now now that Rick's like come
to this realization.
Oh yeah we can fight Negan and Negan just
getting too comfortable in the suburbs, but
the whole thing with Negan beard has been
talked about.
It has something to do with Jeffrey Dean Morgan
being on the good wife and having to have
appeared on that TV show when he came on The
Walking Dead so we had to keep the beard for
a little while but comic book Negan has never
had a beard.
So now he just closer to comic book Negan
the really funny part about this isn't so
much knee can though is is the look on Judith's
face just when you consider that were on.
Like maybe our 10th or 12th baby Judith.
I don't know how many different kids that
they recast as Judith, just because the timeline
of The Walking Dead move so slowly but kids
age.
So fast were running into the same problem
with Carl to so I'll talk about Chandler Riggs
at the end of this there's a lot of talk about
him re-signing his contract.
That's a completely separate thing, so number
eight.
Daryl finally busts out with the help of that
note in that key.
So the handwriting still looks like Sherry's
handwriting in the room that he busts into
looks like the whites that he suddenly realizes
he's looking around like you see the TV set
that Dwight was watching TV on.
You see the peanut butter the funny thing
about the peanut butter like Daryl just goes
to town because he so hungry he's been so
underfed on all that dog food they been giving
him is that Norman Redus is like I can't stand
peanut butter but they probably had to shoot
a couple versions of the season so when they
were filming he probably had to eat a whole
bunch of peanut butter, but I love the way
he acted when he was getting ready to leave
that room like you sitting in the chair is
kind of waiting for his opportunity waiting
for the conversation to die down nearby and
then see the little model with the fortress
and the soldiers and just upends the table
just like screw this guy whoever's room.
This is so he may not have actually known
that it was Dwight's, but I feel like he felt
that was so you know whoever it was, he just
want to trash it just a little bit just like
screw you saviors you guys suck, so number
seven Negan versus Rick's kitchen make some
spaghetti even sets a place for Lucille because
who knows where Rick is well and not wait
anymore past the roles I love how passive
Negan was in this episode.
Usually he's up everyone's faces, but in this
episode he was just trying to enjoy all the
air-conditioning the nice kitchen.
The food, just chill out put his feet up so
the really took the entire episode for him
to get pissed and that was really only when
Rosita took a shot at them but the whole idea
with seems like this is that he's meant to
feel like the unwelcome houseguests that won't
get out like dude, this is our house.
You need to get out of here.
So they just really wanted to beat you in
the face with that.
Now is the time to kick the saviors out of
our house talking about the save zone people
maybe we can agree on this, but did you guys
feel like with the extra emphasis on Olivia
on the episode like that extra long scene
with Tara that almost seem kind of pointless
like she was getting ready to throw herself
on a spear for Negan the save Judith or
just keep everything in Rick's house from
spiraling out of control because she felt
like it was her duty to protect Carl and Judith
that she was gonna die at the end of the episode,
no matter what happened like anytime they
focus this much on a C-list character like
Olivia you know they're getting ready some
big twist to gonna pull the rug out from under
you in some way.
And just because this is the midseason finale
and they haven't killed someone in a while
you will most sense that she's going to be
one of the people to die Spencer could've
gone either way.
He was the more fun kill like I was really
happy they got rid of him, so number six.
Rick and Aaron make their way to the houseboat
to look for supplies.
So the just all kinds of weapons are bulletholes
and everything there bunch of Walker traps.
So the whole point of this scene isn't so
much that they're getting supplies.
It just an opportunity for Aaron to double
down on Rick's cause like he's like, dude.
I'm totally in on what were doing helping
people even if it means that we have to bargain
with the saviors.
I understand what you're doing.
I'm with you.
So the last couple of episodes there's been
this thing with people questioning Rick's
leadership people wondering what was going
on like even Carl went to kill Negan because
he wasn't satisfied with how far Rick was
going so this Aaron scene was really like
the answer to that look there are people that
believe in what you're doing that understand
what's going on the situation were in so they
did have like a fun bait and switch where
Aaron goes under your like oh my God, they
just kill Aaron that he pops back up I'm fine
I'm fine.
I was kind of a metaphor for the episode like
everybody starts drowning.
But then by the end they're all like okay
we're fine, we're gonna fight Negan now.
So number five they make it onto the boat
and they find that middle finger on that piece
of paper that was so hilarious, you win, but
you lose I feel like the reason they included
that was just so that they could have that
moment later with the saviors picking it up
and going, what the hell does this mean you
win, but you lose that was meant to be more
of a metaphor for the saviors and then you
know number four who the hell of those boots
like somebody's been peeping on them, and
there's gonna be a lot of debate about this
during the break because there are a couple
big characters that need to be introduced
in one of those is the whisperers. Those are
big characters.
So there's a female character that leads them
called alpha.
There's also another female character that
leads another small group that's near Alexandria
called magna.
So I think that this character is probably
magna, just because she debuts before alpha
in the whisperers do in the comics so the
thing about this is that the really just teasing
that somebody's watching them you don't know
if they're good you don't know if they're
bad, but there's a character that there casting
called Briand and they haven't announced which
actor's this playing her yet.
So that's probably who this character is and
here's the thing about that the name is not
somebody from the comics but she supposed
to be a tough female character who is the
leader of another group.
So they're basically casting either magna
or somebody from the whisperers or somebody
from a totally new group that I do think that
it's from one of the comic book groups and
the names are using that Briand name is just
fake to misdirect people.
So even though whisperers whisperers war is
something that happens away after all out
war which is something that were not even
close to yet on the TV show you guys can let
me know who do you think these boots belong
to magna or somebody from the whisperers,
we can talk about that during the break, but
number three zero goes full Negan on fat
Jerry I love the way he performed the scene
to Norman Redus he was almost like an animal
in this moment just completely lashing out
but then Jesus comes in and he slowly comes
back to consciousness he starts acting like
a human again okay let's get out of here and
he grabs Rick's revolver so very important
for later.
But can we just appreciate Norman Redus his
performance in this moment here.
He's so great at underperforming Daryl.
Daryl is in somebody that emotes a lot like
he speaks in grunts like that later moment
where he almost breaks down crying and hugs
Rick it's very underperformed compared to
somebody like Jeffrey Dean Morgan doing his
Negan who just pontificates just goes on
and on and just talks his head off.
So Daryl performances are like the exact opposite
of that.
So it's really funny to see him and scenes
with characters that won't shut up, but number
two; shit goes crazy at the save zone. Negan finally got Spencer now we know why they kept
him on the show that long.
He was one of the most unlikable characters
ever.
I hated Spencer so I'm so glad that he's gone
the way he was killed was exactly like the
comics like Negan guts him with his knife
so they've actually been pretty good about
doing like the big deaths exactly the way
they happen in the comics there couple characters
that they don't have from the comics like
Daryl is in a comic book character in they
didn't kill Abraham in the comics.
That way he got killed in a different way.
So there are a few minor changes over the
biggest Deaths they been happening just like
they did in the comics and I love Eugene's
performance here to, just completely breaks
down Negan is taking him because he wants
more bullets and Eugene can make bullets so
even though it sound like he's gonna go kill
him like I'm taking your bullet maker from
you is just because he wants Eugene to mass
produce ammo for the survivors which is actually
very dangerous considering the everyone wants
to take them on.
Now, so a lot of people were blaming Rosita
for the deaths in this episode because she
took a shot at Negan, but Spencer was killed
before she ever took a shot, so that had nothing
to do with Rosita, you could blame Olivia
on Rosita, but the thing about that is that
she was a relatively minor character I don't
feel like they really needed her on the show.
So what they're doing here is there giving
you like the Gore like all my got a couple
people died that have been with us for a while
but there holding off on really big a list
character deaths for season finale.
So if you want to speculate on like a really
huge deaths the just save that for whatever
the season finale is going to be in episode
16, but it was really great seeing the way
they played it in the episode itself wasn't
that crazy like there was just a lot of storylines
that they had to wrap up that they could get
to this moment at the end where they all decide
hey were going to fight Negan, but number
one was Rick getting the revolver back everybody
meeting at hilltop better watch out.
Now, the Sheriff's back in town, so the only
thing that would've made the scene better
is if Rick had taken his hat off of Carl's
head and put it back on but that might've
been too on the nose, you guys can let me
know like what you think about that moment
when Rick took his revolver back check the
bullets and just holstered it like damn time
to get the business.
The ending was the ending that they had needed
to get to for a while.
I feel like one of the big complaints for
the last couple of episodes is that things
had just gotten so depressing, but you can
see why they wanted to do that they wanted
to have this big payoff moment where they
all decide you know based on michonne speech
with Rick hey were still standing here we
can fight back in Rick's like I realize that
now, they just wanted to take their time getting
to that moment dragging the characters through
the mud making Negan feel like the unwelcome
houseguest.
So now I feel like the show can be a little
bit more fun because it can be all about them
making their plans marshaling forces to fight
Negan.
So now we actually have some momentum heading
into the season finale when the show comes
back you guys can let me know like what you
think of this first half of the season and
The Walking Dead there were a couple really
crazy moments, but it was really just all
about the reign of knee can dragging everybody
through the mud.
The breaking of Rick Grimes.
So whatever your complaints were about the
first half of the season.
I feel like it's going to be completely different
in the back half.
They tend to do that with The Walking Dead
every eight episodes they try to change with
the show is so when it comes back should feel
like a totally different experience which
I think is a really good thing can happen
next is I'll do Westworld season two predictions
that I'll do a walking dead trailer video
for the rest of the season so I'll try get
those videos up as fast as possible while
you guys wait for that to post you can click
here for my walking dead playlist and you
can click here to rewatch the fast they trailer
thank you so much watching everybody high
five I'll see you guys tonight!